what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we are going to be
getting a brand new trailer and the
first trailer really for Loki season two
Disney has revealed some footage already
in a little Disney plus sneak peek
special preview type of video they put
out not too long ago but we have yet to
get the first official trailer for Loki
season 2 and it's very important because
this project is going to have a huge
impact on the MCU moving forward with
the Multiverse Saga Loki season 2 is
also going to be pretty big because this
will also kind of determine the fate of
Jonathan Majors Marvel Studios has kept
quiet since Jonathan majors has been
arrested however other companies and
some Studios have let him go his
management company his PR Company and he
has lost some acting roles since his
arrest and the accusations of assault
were pressed against him but it looks
like Marvel is holding on to innocent
until proven guilty Jonathan majors has
already presented a lot of evidence
suggesting that he is indeed in a it is
pretty damning evidence but we'll still
have to wait and see what the Court
decides however based on what we've
heard about some of Marvel studios's
decisions with Jonathan Majors as king
the Conqueror they are prepared to
replace him as king and this will
apparently happen in Loki season 2
provided his case has come to a close
and this will no doubt determine if
Marvel Studios is going to continue to
have Jonathan Majors as king the
Conqueror in the MCU or replace him with
a different actor we'll break down
everything you need to know about the
Loki season 2 trailer and the fate of
Jonathan majors in this video and
reminder our giveaway ends tomorrow if
you would like a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items be sure to subscribe
and leave a comment down below we pick
one random comment and we pick one
winner at the end of each month the
winner gets to pick one item and that
ends tomorrow so Marvel Studios recently
released a new poster for Loki season 2.
many of you have probably seen this
poster already it shows us different
variants of Loki himself running a
around a Miss minutes pocket watch which
is fitting Miss minutes is essentially a
clock and we know that Miss minutes is
going to return for Loki season 2 and we
know that she works for Kang the
Conqueror or he who remains or perhaps
nobody right now since he who remains no
longer remains instead we have many
different variants of Kang the Conqueror
and this shows us many different
variants of Loki possibly the different
variants of Loki that we'll see
throughout season 2 or the different
outfits that he will simply wear perhaps
this is just one Loki but it tells us
that Marvel Studios has officially
decided to keep the October 6th release
date this is not being delayed or pushed
back anything like that it is coming out
October 6th and according to Insider
Daniel rpk we are supposed to be getting
that first Loki trailer Monday and this
seems to be pretty accurate so far
because he also teased that there was
going to be some sort of a Miss minutes
teaser that same day that he announced
when the trailer was coming and then we
got the poster that had missed minutes
and Loki on it and Daniel rpk has a
really good track record of Scooby when
trailers are going to be releasing so
expect the trailer Monday now that could
either be pretty early in the morning as
Marvel does sometimes that could be as
early as 5 a.m Pacific Time possibly
even 4 a.m if Marvel Studios decides to
release it at 7am Eastern time or
sometime at night Marvel Studios usually
does either or that doesn't mean it
can't come sometime in the afternoon
because of course it can but keep your
eyes out on early morning and late in
the afternoon now what's going to be
really interesting about this trailer is
to see if Jonathan Majors as king he who
remains whatever variant of King the
Conqueror Nathaniel Richards is
prominent at the time is in the trailer
because it could be assigned to us of
where Marvel studios's heads are at
right now in regards to recasting
Jonathan Majors as king recently They
delayed putting off the assembled piece
for Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
because of all the things happening with
Jonathan Majors however ultimately they
did release it not too long ago and
Jonathan Majors is in it a lot they
didn't cut him out they didn't edit it
to show him less he was in it quite a
lot and he talked quite a lot so this is
a good sign for Marvel Studios and like
I mentioned he could have met with
Marvel Studios already in fact of course
he's met with Marvel to talk about the
situation but he could have met with
Marvel Studios to specifically show them
his evidence to prove to them hey look
I'm innocent in this please don't fire
me here's my evidence that I'm going to
present to the court based off of what I
have we believe him and his legal team
of course that he's going to be proven
innocent based off of all of this
evidence he could have done that with
Marvel Studios and said please just wait
till the Court decides if I'm innocent
or guilty before you make your decision
to either replace me or not and that's
honestly the right thing to do because
if he is innocent he should not suffer
for false claims against him in which he
really already has his career has taken
a major hit but we've heard from some
insiders that Marvel Studios does have a
plan sort of a plan B for if Jonathan
Majors is found guilty and according to
Alex P from the cosmic circus this comes
in recent reshoots for Loki season two
of course in fact Alex P specifically
stated that we will find out the fate of
Jonathan majors at the end of Loki
season 2. and I believe that is because
Marvel has two different endings planned
perhaps the story kind of ends the same
way but the king who they end the story
with could be quite different or they
could kill off the specific variant of
Jonathan majors and enter a new variant
of Kang played by a new actor a more
villainous and dangerous variant of King
the Conqueror kind of like oh you
thought that King was bad well there's
this other variant out there who happens
to look different who's even worse and
that's how they could set up the new
actor to play Kane to conquer in the MCU
that is apparently the reshoots that
they did based off of what we've been
told we're not sure if they have already
got a new actor who could possibly take
the role of Jonathan Majors or if they
simply state that there's other variants
out there but either way I'm really
curious to see if they show Jonathan
majors in the trailer tomorrow it makes
sense for them to do it considering how
Loki season 1 ended however there is a
lot going on in season 2 to where they
really wouldn't have to show him or they
could simply show the statues of him
since that's what we saw in the finale
of Loki season 1. but we do know Victor
timely is going to be kind of a
prominent character in Loki season 2.
and we already saw him in the post
credits of Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania since they've shown him
already it wouldn't be that hard to show
him in the trailer but again it is
really a sticky situation for Marvel
Studios right now they've already kind
of tried to lay low a little bit they
really stopped talking about Jonathan
Majors during all the after press for
quantumania and the promotions for it
after they only really mention a villain
not even specifically King the Conqueror
and they really didn't mention Jonathan
majors at all then they put off
releasing assembled and this was
attributed to the situation that he's in
right now I'm also curious to see our
new characters like kihoi Kwan's
character to see what they're about and
of course as many people know this is
going to directly connect to Deadpool 3.
we know that Owen Wilson's Mobius is
going to be in Deadpool 3 and it's even
been said that Miss minutes is going to
be in Deadpool 3. and Deadpool's gonna
kind of flirt with her a little bit
which I totally believe because that's
such a Ryan Reynolds and Deadpool joke
but I am curious to see if we're gonna
see any Deadpool 3 connections in Loki
season 2 since it comes out before are
we gonna see a variant of Deadpool
simply in the background of the TVA
somewhere I would love to see a
wolverine variant but since he is coming
back after such a long time and it's his
MCU debut no way they show us that
before but maybe Deadpool maybe some
sort of a connection there but either
way we are super excited for Loki season
2 the official trailer that is supposed
to be coming Monday if we hear anything
about the actual time whether that's in
the morning or afternoon we'll be sure
to do a quick little update maybe a
community post so look out for that and
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos specifically
our Loki season 2 trailer breakdown and
of course subscribe and leave a comment
down below it is the second to last day
to end enter our giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox series X A PS5 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
you can also find us on patreon you can
check out our website our Discord server
and of course you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf